les marques c'est fini place aux paquets
neutres depuis le 1er janvier seuls ces
types de paquets sont vendus une mesure
peu convaincante pour certains fumeurs
moi je suis contre pourquoi parce que
c'est pas ça qui empêchera les gens de
fumer ça votre chien pour les buralistes
way pour retrouver dans l'étape à cavan
cité rouge vert et cetera mais
maintenant ça va des faits c'est pour
eux c'est de la folie et c'est une
aberration
parce que ça sert à rien le plus
dégueulasse des paquets noah avec des
images choquantes pour inciter à arrêter
de fumer
une contrainte selon les buralistes qui
ont écoulé les stocks des dernières
cigarettes classiques
le ministre nous a affirmé que tous nos
fournisseurs ne reprendrait des paquets
non vendus donc ce qui nous permet de ne
pas avoir de pertes
quand on reçoit les commandes tout est
plus de la même couleur même format
c'est c'est horrible pour travailler
c'est ta pas été du tout pensé pour nous
en tout cas on comprend pas l'impact que
cela peut avoir
je suis en vie ce n'est tout noir le
prix est efficace je pense que aussi
c'est de la prévention de l'éducation
et puis mes l'interdît l'interdît n'a
jamais n'a jamais
couper court à la consommation autre
levier du gouvernement pour lutter
contre le tabagisme la fiscalité la loi
de finances de la sécurité sociale de
2017 prévoit une taxe spécifique sur les
fournisseurs et un relevé du taux sur le
tabac à rouler